another victory for you and now you're
in second place uh congratulations that
must feel pretty good you've been
laboring quite hard to get to where you
are right now yeah I mean I haven't like
really I've just been like relaxing
before the game like I haven't like done
any press basically and it worked today
I have to say and take us through the
game tell us I think like about the
moment the critical moment I think so
Queenie too like after Knight B7 I feel
like she probably could have like
improved like Queen maybe like Queen F6
I thought but like I feel like she
played like a little oh too slow and
like allow me to get like C4 and I see
theory in and she didn't really really
have like a king side attack I know
you're pressuring everything on the
queen side
and then slowly slowly yeah
very nice travel and transfer the Knight
to C6 Knight D4 another nice uh little
trick to get the exchange
congratulations riyanka definitely
feeling good you cannot win the
tournament at this point but you're
still fighting for a second position is
that the goal and how are you going to
approach tomorrow's game well I'm trying
not think about too much because I feel
like it's just gonna stress me out even
more so I'm just gonna like play like
you know normally play what I usually
play and just hopefully win the last
round well Ryan you're definitely on the
right track you've been showing great
chess in the last few rounds we'll see
you tomorrow
our congratulations as well